we are not happy with that whole
situation because we believe it could
have been stopped at the source it could
have been stopped quickly and it
wouldn't have spread all over the world
that we think that should have happened
so we'll let you know what the
appropriate time but we are doing
serious investigations president Trump
just moments ago as health officials in
China say that the last kovat 19
patients in Wuhan have now been released
from the hospital a major milestone for
the city where the pandemic first began
but the government announcement comes as
Fox News reports that China may have had
up to 50 times more cases than they have
admitted or reported officially trump
administration official telling Fox News
quote we don't know the real numbers
today but we do know that the about
80-thousand infection and four thousand
death numbers reported by the Chinese
Communist Party propaganda are not even
remotely close here now Senator Lindsey
Graham chairman of the Judiciary
Committee Senator Graham good to have
you here tonight you know obviously it's
very difficult to believe what's coming
out of China in terms of of these
numbers I'm just gonna pop up the
population numbers for everybody at home
so they can get a look at this China's
population 1.4 billion they say that
they lost 4,600 people the United States
has 328 million and we have you know
been fully transparent about the fact
that we've lost 56 nearly 56,000 right
now just take a look at Wuhan versus New
York Wuhan is 11 million people 3,800
deaths
New York City 8.4 million 17 and a half
million deaths what's going on here oh
that's Chinese Communist Party BS that's
what's going on here here's what we do
know 26 million Americans that vital
work are out of work because of this
virus almost 56,000 Americans are dead
because this virus it came from China
I'm not saying they intentionally did
this a combination of gross negligence
plus wilful deception by the Chinese
government led to this and here's my
plea to my Democratic colleagues please
don't give China pass for this pandemic
work with me to compel China to do three
things that need to be done
number one fully cooperate with
any investigation regarding how the
virus originated US and international
community number to close all the wet
markets that serve exotic wildlife like
bats and monkeys where a lot of this
comes from and three release all the
Hong Kong democracy advocates that have
been jailed since the virus started
we're going to put sanctions on China
too they do those three things and I
need Democrats Democrats have been very
silent when it comes to China please do
not give China a pass all right so I
mean we've heard a number of proposals
coming out of Congress to crack down on
China you know what are their teeth in
this it tell me about the sanctions so
if they don't do those three things
we're given one of those three things
what's going to happen to them that's a
great question one we're going to seize
assets of Chinese officials that are
responsible for not reporting the
pandemic we're going to cut China all
from US financial institutions we're
going to shut down visa travel into the
United States for Chinese students we're
going to close off America to China the
Chinese economy and we're going to make
it hard for them to do business in the
United States until they fully cooperate
close the wet markets and release the
hong kong democracy advocates there's
real teeth in this bill but the only way
it will really have teeth if it's is
bipartisan so to the democratic party
join me and president Trump and all
Republicans to send a signal to China
business as usual is over until you
change your behavior you know it's
interesting that polls that we've seen
show that the American people are really
waking up to this issue and that they
don't want us to be dependent on China
anymore and I find that fascinating it
you know sort of reminds me of the the
made-in-the-usa movement that was around
in the late 70s early 80s and you know I
actually have a little clip from one of
those one of those jingles that I'm
going to play go ahead let's play that
[Music]
[Applause]
do you remember those that's the union
workers ladies you know workers by the
Union I think that yeah I mean I think
that if you you had a real make it in
the USA movement in this country at this
moment I think you could get a lot of
momentum behind that why don't we see
that yet it's called the Trump campaign
it's called the Trump campaign how did
Trump get to be Preston he said I'm
gonna stand up to China cheating I'm
gonna stand up to China stealing our job
stealing our intellectual property
ripping us off manipulating their
currency one of the biggest reasons that
Donald Trump is president United States
he saw the behavior of China to be
unacceptable every other president
before him is given China pass he's not
gonna give China pass I hope the
Democratic Party who's talked tough in
the past about China will step up and
work with me to make sure we find out
what happened in China if they don't
cooperate they lose access to the US
economy number two shut these wet
markets this is the third pandemic to
come out of wet markets and and three
release these democracy advocates in
Hong Kong as the world's been focused on
Bakr oh no virus they've been putting
everybody in jail in Hong Kong
demonstrating for democracy so enough
with China already Trump's all this
before everybody I'm gonna give
Democrats a chance he's yeah I mean the
president's been very tough on China
when it comes to the trade deal very
tough on it in a lot of ways but he also
says you know President Xi is my friend
and I'm not gonna do anything really
dramatic unless he reneged on this trade
deal he's definitely holding out on that
trade deal as one last connection to
China and their economy you can you can
tell from what he says yeah well one
this guy's not our friend a friend would
not let this happen to somebody that
they considered to be a friend a friend
would not sit silently by and protect
his own country while the rest of the
world gets it affected now China is
somebody we have to do business with I
want a good relationship with China but
they got to earn it so this is a chance
for the Democratic and Republican
parties to come together we we've come
together back here at home by putting
money on the table to help Americans get
through the Quran
we need to come together when it comes
to punishing China to make sure it
doesn't happen again if they get away
with it this time they'll do it again
so enough enough enough is enough
there's no doubt you know we've spent
decades working on energy independence
which we finally achieved absent the
current energies energy situation and
you know I think there is a movement in
this country to want independence from
China and we'll see if that's what we
get and we'll be watching your your your
bill as it as you try to get it to move
through the process Thank You senator
well we have a vote on it
I hope we have a vote on it thank you
good we'll look forward to it thank you
very much